using the rim right there against the
shop Locker
[Applause]
damn Whitmore through contact
speaking of grown men yes yes some of
the older Statesmen Elder Statesman
coming in with some of this young talent
for Houston I think that is so important
and everyone says
that guy's a world-class athlete and
then the name of the guys that are
superstars in their role
and Tyrese is going to have a role in
this league for a long time
and cam Whitmore is hoping to do the
same dropped all the way to 20. yeah
really nice job little roll replaced
bring Wiseman behind the play looking to
go high low they don't respect the
jumper he knocks it down
go inside a Whitmore Two Shots two dunks
Point Blank
the Pistons looking to make a move up
from the depths of the NBA standings
Whitmore hit a good first quarter and
starts the second with a shotgun
yesterday in the Rockets opening he also
saw Ben Sullivan
we spent a couple of years in Boston
including Whitby May and
cam Whitmore with a triple good contest
on the perimeter Cameron Whitmore this
is a deep three just a little bit of a
rhythm dribble and a side step knocks
down that three
[Music]
[Applause]
it's been a struggle for Sasser today
gave it up and turned it over
Whitmore
opening tip between the Thunder and the
rockets
and they tip it around Whitmore gets it
and the 20th pick in the draft gets the
first bucket of the game
Hudgens
finds Whitmore
killer cam the best shot selection but
move without the Rock and it'll pay off
cam Whitmore and the Houston Rockets up
by four early in the
[Music]
Whitmore in the corner hounded by
McConnell Baseline jumper wow
Whitmore attacking that's a grown man
move right there and a great finish
Whitmore running the floor
that's Williams
the hyper athleticism
you're Jackson Davis their second round
pick this year and the pass picked off
Whitmore
rookie took it from a rookie and that'll
come out to Whitmore
Whitmore from range got it with Fred
they've addressed that and the
championship pedigrees
of green and Van Bleek and the toughness
of Brooks
get him get a ring and get a nice
paycheck get a get a nice paycheck bring
some more games to Vegas yeah his IQ is
off the charts he's he's Fearless he's
tough
um he can rebound really can pass the
ball he has not shot it well in the
summer league but the lack of confidence
he does not have
well we're seeing some of the things
that Larry Harris was excited about with
Trace
from Larry Harris mentioning is Cam
Whitmore hits another three mentioning
the different ways
from Steven Silas to email adoka one of
the six changes this year Philly Toronto
Milwaukee Detroit Phoenix
tried to hook up the back door good
defense in the takeaway for Golden State
and then the Rockets get it right back
look out wait for
Spirit of this Houston Rockets ball Club
here you go in the backcourt the
pressure with more elevating
[Applause]
there's Hudgens out top
got a mismatch
Whitmore drives the catch and slabs it
all we've seen him Nate Hinton has done
that this afternoon getting in the right
headspace George yeah Nate Hinton has
had a couple
you make about
where the Atlanta Hawks stand and what
they did during the off season recently
signing dejounte Murray to an extension
amongst other things more than two max
players and they're going to be faced
with some difficult choices
[Music]
Kinsley out here in transition went with
the John Wall reverse outside of just
the shooting
[Music]
Whitmore down
here in the weight room there
we've seen the full skill set tonight I
think they're passing the off the bounce
game posting up offensive rebounds even
knock down a triple
Whitmore with a short jump shot for him
it's just continue to grow he's scored
at Elite level already at his his young
age but we wanted to continue to grow as
an all-around player
pardon me it's Brent Haskell
what a classy slick finish by Whitmore